et à quand le budget du gouvernement
trudeau avec nous serge coulombe
économiste professeur émérite au
département de sciences économiques à
l'université d'ottawa
bonsoir monsieur coulombe dans soins aux
étudiants plaisir de vous retrouver les
partis d'opposition demandent au
gouvernement plus de transparence des
projections un budget un énoncé
économique ont-ils raison oui je pense
que c'est un bon point que les partis
d'opposition font faut comprendre
cependant qu'on vit dans une situation
extrêmement particulière qui est
extrêmement changeantes et ce n'est pas
facile de faire un budget waouh on
prévoit les revenus et les dépenses pour
l'année qui est alors que on sait
vraiment pas où va aller l'économie au
cours de la prochaine année
mais n'empêche je pense que je serai en
grès a dit qu'en dépit de cette très
forte incertitude
le gouvernement devrait présenter un
budget et maintenant les meilleures
données que nous avons c'est celle du
directeur parlementaire du budget oui
qui s'incruste lui des sommes qu'il
faudra investir pour relancer l'économie
est-ce que c'est soutenable qui est en
train de se passer mais ces dépôts
soutenable sur une base de trois années
consécutives par exemple et il faut
comprendre que le déficit excédentaire
de 235 millions de dollars camp nou
depuis le début de cette crise va en
bonne partie s'estomper lorsque les
mesures qui ont été mises l'avant dès le
début pour garder l'économie dans un
dans un coma artificiel
l'appréciation l'état d'urgence et
éventuellement la subvention salariale
vont s'estomper
donc évidemment ça va prendre d'autres
milliards de dollars pour relancer
l'économie mais ça va coûter beaucoup
moins cher de relancer l'économie que ça
aux côtés pour legrand a pris la place
de l'économie
les gens ne pouvaient plus travailler ne
mèneraient plus doigts ne voulait plus
travailler et le grenat a simplement
payer les salaires
donner de l'argent aux entreprises et
aux ménages de façon à les garder à flot
financièrement
lorsque ce sera le temps d'avoir une
relance économique et maintenant on
rentre dans cette phase
à part la prestation la subvention
salariale
les autres dépenses c'est pour dépenses
de programme on peut s'attendre à
quelques dizaines de milliards de
dollars
mais je ne l'espère pas de centaines de
milliers alors tant qu'il y aura pas de
deuxième vague évidemment et si une
deuxième vague
ce conte par la machine avec des
dizaines et des centaines de milliards
il faut comprendre que le canada ont les
moyens financièrement de continuer avec
un régime un peu équivalent ce qu'on a
maintenant pour quelques temps parce que
le canada avait au début de la crise le
plus fort taux d'endettement des pays de
l'oci dix heures et de plus il compte
sur une banque centrale qui a financé
une grosse partie des dépenses que de
cette crise la banque du canada a accru
ses effectifs de l'ordre de 3 124
milliards de dollars de tout début de la
crise
c'est ainsi sans précédent et d'un seuil
120 milliards de dollars d'achat des
titres du gouvernement fédéral des vents
et des obligations
donc je sais bien c'est une image 5
monsieur fillion là mais on ne sait pas
nécessairement mauvais de dire qu'il ya
au moins la moitié des dépenses du gore
fédéral pour la coved qui en sont
financés par la création monétaire de la
banque fim à tort par les pays européens
qui sont en moins bonne situation
financière pour commencer n'ont pas
accès à une banque centrale qui est prêt
à signer des chèques en blanc au
gouvernement pour relancer l'économie on
a vu tous les programmes que les
européens iront avec la manne qui qui
qui poursuit la banque centrale
européenne en disant que l
pas le droit de voler au secours des
autres ont la main d'or au canada
on est un peu comme les états unis on a
une part centrale qui présentement
travaillent main dans la main avec le
ministère des finances
et dans les deux corps autant au niveau
budgétaire qu'au niveau
mon état au niveau des acquisitions
d'actifs en proportion du pib
les ford de du gouvernement fédéral et
de la bonne terre ne se compare en
pourcentage au pib à ce qui est fait aux
états unis ce qui n'est pas
nécessairement une mauvaise idée parce
que comprenait que les deux l'économie
ont été frappés par le même virus
alors si on s'envoie un défi de 250 300
milliards la date elle va monter à près
de 1000 milliards
est-ce que la note de crédit du canada
pourrait être en jeu
non je ne pense pas repasser indicateur
pour les raisons me fait dire que je
vous ai dit on va se ramasser avec une
des ratios dette au pib en prenant le
pib 2019 la présente mais sans nouvelles
aux dépenses encore eu environ 2 43% 4
47% pensent que le pib de 2020 est
beaucoup plus faible
on est très loin des européens non c'est
beaucoup plus inquiétant du côté de
certaines provinces canadiennes comme
terre-neuve surtout mais également
éventuellement l'alberta mais sachez que
la banque centrale ont également acheté
des titres des provinces pour continuer
à faciliter l'accès des prisons marchés
financiers donc non je pense que les
titres du gouvernement fédéral canadien
et les titres du gouvernement fédéral
américain
présentement de même que les qualités de
l'allemagne sont parmi les non liquides
les plus en demande sur les marchés
internationaux
les taux d'intérêt sont extrêmement
faibles et tout ceci découle de la
compréhension et le système or que le
canada les etats-unis ont un accès
direct
à la banque centrale et on n'est pas
donc vous excluez les déficits
structurels là où ce danger des défis
structurels au canada à l'étudiant pour
connaître un déficit structurel on a
besoin de savoir où l'économie va se
retrouver en bout de ligne
fall et moi je le sais pas il ya
personne qu'il sait ça peut être aussi
beau que 10 % plus faible que le niveau
de pib qu'on avait auparavant donc ok
encore clairement avoir un difficile
mais une partie importante de déficit
budgétaire devrait normalement
disparaître au fur et à mesure auteur de
un an et demi à 12 ans merci beaucoup
serge coulon pour cette analyse ce soir
au plaisir